le salon du livre de paris c'est plus de
160 mille visiteurs 3900 hauteur pour
lesquels il faut parfois se montrer
patient pour avoir une dédicace et de
grands noms de l'édition par milieu des
petites maisons compte bien profiter de
l'événement pour se faire connaître
arrêt au stand eu 57 c'est notre
troisième année une vaste salon du livre
on a commencé en 2000
16 avec un
en 2017 avec un petit stand coup de
pouce c'est les tout petits stands pour
les éditeurs débutants ou les propos les
auteurs autoédités et l'année dernière
on a appris un stand qui ressemblait à
celui ci un sens dans les pistes année
on a réitéré l'expérience butterfly
édition est né en 2016 à thoiry sa
spécialisation la romance un genre
littéraire qui conquis son public
surtout en version numérique
c'est l'occasion pour eux de rencontrer
nos livres papier de discuter avec les
auteurs des changes et qu'on se rende
compte que des deux côtés auteurs ou aux
lecteurs c'est formidable pour eux
quatre mois de préparation pour réussir
à faire venir une vingtaine d'auteurs en
dédicace un week-end intense
alors en ce dernier jour consacré aux
professionnels on en profite pour faire
des rencontres
ariane et chroniqueurs spécialisés dans
la romance elle a justement fait la
critique de l'un des romans de butterfly
édition c'est vrai que c'est un
microcosme
très particulier dans la littérature
l'art annonce et c'est un plaisir de
pouvoir rencontrer les gens avec qui on
communique toute l'année par mail ou
pour les différents services presse donc
c'est l'occasion pour nous de pouvoir
rencontrer tout le monde en étant sûr
salon et de paris d'après le centre
national du livre 92% des français se
déclarent lecteurs en 2019 en poche ou
sous format numérique le livre est
encore prêt à nous faire vivre de
nombreuses histoires